did she sign you up to do a Shrek Airbnb
yeah cuz I saw this footage and it's
incredible most of the great and
interesting things in my life is because
of Rita say she's very random I love it
she she an article came out the Airbnb
had made this Shrek replica of the of
Shrek's house in the middle of Scotland
like way out in the middle of
nowhere and yeah you look so creepy
everyone would think that we had a photo
you know camera crew and stuff that was
just us two driving to the middle of
nowhere she painted herself green she
revealed she had brought these costumes
and that we were getting
content oh my gosh and you were like I I
didn't realize this romantic trip was
about content I just I just love
picturing being romantic looking like
those characters being romantic yeah
that would that would be really hard for
me to to to ignore yeah and our accents
our accents oh no we have your accents
let's hear your shk accents here we go
we got some footage
he who's this F I told you I don't like
visitors oh don't mind him oh we old
grum pit pants he's just an ogre he
needs no harm sure don't you talk about
me at that
woman oh
God I think my accent is better than my
accent is better than his sure I am just
saying I'm to get to say I can't get
away from the fact that y'all like I
really hope you made out in those
costumes there was no there's no way I
could with a big rubber
mask we did that and we like sat there
in these ridiculous outfits eating
dinner in a in Shrek's house and then
wases the pain off your face she like
okayy well we did that now what like
left but how funny is that I just love
the randomness of what a fun
relationship couple goals I like it
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home